fanshop.org
good evening everybody and welcome my
name is sabir and i run events here at
the strand
before we launch into a discussion of
craig unger's newest title american
compromise i'd like to share a little
bit of history about the strand
the train was founded in 1927 by
benjamin bass over on fourth avenue's
book rome stretching from union square
to astor place book road gradually
dwindled from 48 book stores no after 94
years the strand is a soul survivor
now run by third generation owner nancy
bass white and we want to thank all of
you for your support without our loyal
community of book lovers we wouldn't be
here today and we are so appreciative of
it
so tonight we are thrilled to have with
us craig unger and yuri spence for the
launch of craig's newest book american
compromise greg unger is the author of
six books including the new york times
bestsellers house of trump house of
putin and house of bush house of zod
for 15 years he was a contributing
editor for vanity fair where he covered
national security the middle east and
other political issues
a frequent analyst on msnbc and other
broadcast outlets he was a long time
staffer in new york magazine
has served as editor-in-chief of boston
magazine and has contributed to esquire
the new yorker and many other
publications
unger has written about the trump-russia
scandal for the new republic vanity fair
in the washington post
he's a graduate of harvard university
and lives in brooklyn new york
yuri schwetz was a major in the edb
during the years 1980 through 1990
from april 1985 to 1987 he worked in the
dc residentiura the pgu kgb sssr
rex has long been a vocal critic of
vladimir putin with whom he was a
college mate at the academy of the kgb
foreign intelligence
since 1998 schwetz has been doing
private business security investigations
in the former soviet union for american
and british businesses
including major banks hedge funds world
top airspace and international oil
companies
in 2020 he consulted with the committee
on banking and financial services the
united states house of representatives
and russian intelligence
activities and money laundering in the
us
in 1995 he published washington station
my life as a kgb spy in america
joining craig and urian conversation is
scott horton
scott is a human rights advocate best
known for his representation of russian
physicist and nobel laureate andrei
sakharov
as well as other figures in the russian
democracy and human rights movement he
is also a lecturer at columbia
university law school and a contributing
editor at harper's magazine where he
writes on legal and national security
affairs
he has authored several books including
the lords of secrecy the national
security elite and america's stealth
warfare and private security contractors
at war
a study of the modern use of mercenaries
he is also a member of the board of the
national institute of military justice
andrei sakharov foundation and the
american branch of the international law
association
and so without further ado please join
me in welcoming craig scott and yuri to
the stage
brand has as a bookstore as a unique
position
uh in new york and in the united states
it's just uh
its miles and miles of books
um are something that captivated me when
i first came to new york in 1980
and i can't even begin to told the
number of hours i've spent meandering
them and buying far more books than uh
than i than any um
intelligent person would ever buy
but i've benefited from it a lot over
the years and i'm
really delighted to see the strand as a
survivor
and also really pleased to see it expand
into
into this area so without any more i'd
like to go straight into the book we
have
craig unger
noted
author
and we have
a key
subject of the book as well a
person whose interviews
go
right to the heart of it
and i think i'd just like to to launch
right off
with a question that is perhaps teed up
by one of the recent
reviews of the book the one written by
john cipher and published in the
washington post about a week ago
in which he has i
as best i can see really nothing
critical or no questions uh to raise
about uh about any of the accounts that
are furnished in the book more to the
contrary he sees them all as
almost obvious things um with it with a
few
which are very uh
cleverly uh presented in the raid but i
think he he at the end raises this issue
of
you've given us a
um an excellent compilation
of what has been reported previously uh
on these subjects
but um what here is new what what is
something that really justifies the
purchase of a new book so craig that
that one's for you
right well uh it's interesting that john
cipher who of course was a long-time
former cia agent
should ask that question because what's
new is
this is the first detailed narrative of
how the kgb cultivated donald trump
and when you look over all the incidents
i report it's true many of them have
been mentioned before
but that key fact has been omitted again
and again and again
and the the narrative starts mostly in
1980 when you see trump buying hundreds
of tv sets from his uh electronics store
owned by soviet emigrates that much has
been reported before what's new
is that the owner
was according to yuri uh
a so-called uh spotter agent for the kgb
and in selling those tv sets he was sort
of opening the door to potentially
recruit donald trump as an asset for the
kgb and that kind of thing goes through
the entire narrative you see again when
when trump is being invited uh to what
is then the soviet union to moscow uh
that's been reported before what hasn't
been reported is how the people who are
doing that are tied to the kgb that one
of them worked uh in the united nations
library that that was a place uh where
uh the kgb uh reserved special spots for
kgb agents
um that when they got there when when
trump finally got to the soviet union uh
he was being force-fed against through
yuri and i've been able to corroborate a
lot of this through other sources but he
was being force-fed talking points that
were published in the new york times the
washington post and the boston globe and
they sort of inflated trump's ego and
made him and think he was i mean this is
kind of ridiculous if we
knowing donald trump as we know him he
was in a a playboy phase as we all know
back then in the mid 80s it was in 87
that he finally met jeffrey epstein they
had parties with 28 girls and two guys
and suddenly during the same period
trump is presenting himself as this
expert on foreign policy
that he's so interested in arcane issues
like uh soviet relationship to japan
that he takes ads out in newspapers
uh that i think believe i believe gives
a whole new dimension to
things like the ad that he took out
during that period which of course as
yuri will tell you um
was really uh yuri was back in russia
in that in september of 1987
and uh he got uh
an internal memo saying that this was
really an active measure by a new asset
and it included the ad i just mentioned
which was signed by donald trump so that
you see that throughout the entire book
well so let's go straight to yuri i mean
you know let me let me just start by
asking
um
what
uh what is it about donald trump
that would have been so interesting so
appealing
to russian intelligence back in the
1980s i mean after all he's just a real
estate developer in in new york not at
that point even a particularly high
profile one you know based in queens
the glamour days were coming a little
bit later i think so what was it about
him that really would have attracted and
then how do we make the link from the
hypothetical that he would have been
of interest to them to
the conclusion that he was and he was
recruited efforts were made to recruit
him what are the specific signs you see
that show that
well uh first i would like to add some
words to the previous question because i
believe it's very important
i'm surprised by this opinion that it's
just compilation of everything which has
been in the public domain
in fact i haven't seen
anything in public domain before this
book
which would show
exact
connection involvement of the russian
intelligence community
with trump donald trump there were
opinions they were speculations but they
haven't been a single fact i haven't
seen a single name of a kgb guy or fsb
guy i haven't seen any detailed factual
account of how it happened so this book
basically
it is
a
case file professional case file on how
it actually happened how donald trump
was spotted by the russian by the kgb
intelligence
how he was cultivated or developed as
they say in the kgb
and how it all
culminated in what
we had in 2016 when he was the election
elected the president so everything
which
relates to donald trump and his
relations with the russian intelligence
in this book is new at least for me
uh
why he drew attention
uh we need to remember that it was
the time of the cold war
it was the last
the biggest splash of the cold war
and at that time to recruit an american
citizen as an agent it was like for a
regular pilot to fly to the moon and
return back
it was considered almost a mission
impossible
and our biggest chief at the time was
saying that recruits me any american
and we will find a way to use it
forever to use him or her for our
advantage
uh
on the other hand
we had
i mean the soviet union
and the pgp intelligence had had by that
time
a very good
but elderly assets his name was herman
hammer
a billionaire which had been used by the
kgb and the kremlin
and their assets since the days of the
bolshevik revolution he met vladimir
lenin
he did a lot of good things
for the kremlin but
by
the 80s he was in his 90.
he was pretty old he needed the kgb
needed a replacement
so donald trump from this perspective
was a very good candidate to replace
armand hammer as fellow man
in the high-level business cycles of the
united states which by itself was viewed
as important
uh segments of penetration for the kgb
intelligence
uh
[Music]
third consideration was that
he had set a certain characteristics
which
led kgb to believe
that he has a good future
i would remind you that um
uh
in in the kgb in their history they had
a very good case
when in the 1930s they
recruited in
cambridge a group of students
which later became known as cambridge 5
who later
in the 40s and 50s became very prominent
in individuals in the british
intelligence service in the british
foreign office and provided a wealth of
information so the kgb
was and is its successors uh very
patient and they very
and they like to work on the so-called
perspective agent meaning they recruit a
developer today
and then
several years later you have a president
elect
and this is exactly what happened
um
i i i have another question that comes
from a um
a very well-known former cia
officer
uh milt burden
uh with whom i chatted
briefly about your book
um
and uh and his immediate reaction was to
say that
at some point in the near future
there'll be a walk-in
in a cia
station somewhere in the world maybe
mexico or maybe some city in europe or
africa
and a
um a russian agent
seeking to defect and looking for an
american passport
maybe a condo and veil
and a lot of money
will say he has the file
that documents this entire relationship
and he has a list of demands for it
starting with a big cash
uh request
um and so i'd like to ask you to think
you know
do you see that as a um as a possibility
in the future
and and if something like that happens
you know how would a uh cia station
chief have to react to something like
that
is that for me or you're yeah i think
it's for both of you but maybe you want
to go first craig so all right well i
think they're parts of it yuri is better
equipped to answer but i i think um
uh
you know one of the most horrifying
things about this is there's been no
counterintelligence investigation and i
think that's extraordinary so i think we
have to get to the bottom of this or it
will happen again
uh there's no question that trump's
power has plundered him and he's no
longer nearly as important uh to russia
as he was as a weapon so it's quite
possible that at some point in the
future and i don't know when that would
be
uh
that uh someone might feel free to open
it but i don't think it's in the
immediate future but i again i defer to
yuri
uh
who but what what do you think
specifically it's worth to the united
states why would the us be showing out
millions of dollars now
that trump is a retiree what's the value
well i i think when you look over what
happened with trump uh again it has not
been investigated and if we don't
investigate it it will happen again and
if you read my book you can go to
various points where there are all sorts
of things that that uh opened the door
for what was initially a very banal
transaction buying television sets that
sort of morphed over time over 40 years
into
the biggest most powerful uh
intelligence operation perhaps in
history
so what how and why did that happen and
you we have to examine it if we're going
to prevent it again
yuri
yes scott
you ask a very complicated question
there are several questions which may
take hours in uh
kgb or svr
uh
we don't have an hour
to lecture yeah
all right so
i'll try to be concise first
uh
yes i believe they will be
individuals
on the russian side who
i believe within the next several months
i even
said the timeline would work in
somewhere
into the u.s government institution and
offer some intelligence information
possibly related to donald trump
why i said say so because there is a
transition of power in moscow right now
from putin who is losing it
to
his potential successors
and unfortunately potential successors
are the fsb
led by nikolai patricia
these guys are terrorists actually this
is the same guys who blew up
buildings in moscow in 99 to bring putin
to power
they were the ones who poisoned latrine
in london then skripal's family is in
salisbury recently police navalny in
russia so these are monsters but
as the history shows us
succession of power in moscow
usually leads to leakage of sensitive
intelligence information because
different factions
they need to get in touch with
appropriate agencies of the us
government for different reasons
and for this they offer information
so i expect that within and i'm getting
actually signals which i treat as
reliable as serious that within the
uh
few months
uh
the offer for intelligence information
will be coming
second aspect of this question is this
um it's a
burden
suggest that
it may be a good idea just to sit tight
at the embassy and wait for what we call
walk in
or volunteer who recruited himself and
then comes as a gift to the embassy like
aldrich aims came to the soviet embassy
and says guys
i'm yours
i need money i have secrets let's let's
what you know
i call this walkings a miracle
because it's not a product of work of
this station intelligence station
miracle can happen tomorrow or it can
happen 25 years from now and if we sit
and wait for the miracle to happen we'll
definitely have another 911
and
we may have an onslaught and non-stop
penetration of hostile intelligence
services into the united states
so
i believe another strategy is much
better proactive strategy so we better
get out of the embassy go into the
street we look for information we
recruit agents we
guaranteed bits of information then
connect the dots
and this way we can in advance
understand
what the bad guys are preparing for us
uh so i would in brief i would answer
this way
so so craig and yuri have more or less
the same response here which is that we
shouldn't sit back and wait for it but
we should be going after
to unravel everything and complete a
counterintelligence
investigation
well
it seems to me that
whenever anyone
unravels or exposes a major
intelligence operation to push back and
this is probably true just about
anywhere in the world and with any
intelligence operation the pushback is
pretty much always
to point the finger at the people who
are doing the exposing and accuse them
of being tin hatted lunatics
conspiracy theorists
so so i'll just put that on the table
for you so
you know this is um
this is conspiracy theory squared so
it's not only all of this you know uh
russian manchurian candidate
stuff
uh that the attorney general barr told
us had been totally debunked and trump
himself has
thousands of times said it's debunked
it's not true it's crazy uh it's also
we've also folded in opus dei you know
another
uh another
sort of conspiracy theory that um that's
propelled uh hollywood to any number of
feature motion pictures uh but you know
there's very very little about it that
can actually be documented so you know
so how do you respond to that so craig
you're up first okay well i think if you
look at all the con i mean there's a lot
of talk of conspiracy theorists and all
that and i i think everything is a
mirror image of what it's criticizing so
in in fact you you do have if you look
at the epstein scandal the jeffrey
epstein scandal you do have pedophiles
you do have horrifying pedophilia and
sex traffic and all that but it's
reflected
uh when you see people like marjorie uh
taylor greene uh and various other
right-wing uh nuts i think saying that
they're satanic pedophiles in the
basement of the comet pizza place in
washington
uh you you see that kind of thing going
on and on it
from the right uh the conspiracies that
really took place the corruption is
mind-boggling beyond belief uh you you
look at the leon black case uh where he
paid 158 million dollars this is
according to the new york times uh to
jeffrey epstein and for what uh for tax
advice i don't think so um
you know there had to be compromise in
that at
in one way or another and i think that's
an element you see running through all
this that you see you do see compromise
factories these are
compromided of course is compromising
material and it's a bit like extortion
or blackmail it's being held over people
so there's a lot of that going on and
when you you investigate the whole
uh spectrum it is sort of remarkable i
mean when i was talking
uh to yuri he identified trump as a
as a
special unofficial contact and when you
look at other people who've held that
that kind of been in that kind of
category it's not just armed hammer it's
people like robert maxwell who is glenn
maxwell's father
um and so there's an awful lot going on
in a very very dark world there are
trillions and trillions of dollars in
dark money
uh that that are being laundered and put
back in our economy much of it from
russia from uh from the middle east as
well in china
um
so it's it's a period of just
extraordinary corruption and you know
conspiracies is really i think i mean
you're the lawyer but it's more than one
person committing a crime really and and
working together and that does happen
um that's exactly right and of course
you know we we some conspiracies in fact
occur
regularly they get regularly charged in
in criminal cases
the problem here is uh is the issue of
proof uh that of course a um
a professionally managed
active measures campaign involves lots
of people who have been trained
professionally for years to avoid
leaving a trail with the sort of
evidence that can be used for legal
levels of proof yuri am i right
yeah absolutely the first requirement a
requirement of any intelligent
separation is confidentiality
or conspiracy conspiracy this is how
they call it in in russia so there's the
biggest requirement not to leave any
traces
and
until recently until putin they had been
pretty good at this
so if you sit and wait until bullet free
or bulletproof evidence which you can
take to the court you lose this game you
need to to look for tick bits of
information
you can get
and then you have to analyze it and it's
by the way i can tell you the analysis
analysis of case file of information
when i was trained in this intelligence
academy
we were trained 24
24 7 basically
there we lived
in the outskirts in the woods of moscow
and
we had most of the time
for
uh
for for training in foreign languages
uh
after the foreign language
the most time was spent on
analysis
we had a crowd in our group for instance
about 18 guys and most of them could
perfectly make a dead drop load the drop
unload that rope detect surveillance
avoid surveillance but just two guys had
excellent on analysis
so it's a hard real job but you should
know this uh in order to do the analysis
now just a few words about uh conspiracy
series with respect to this book
um
what i
what we did on trump kgb connection was
uh craig
it's not an article it's not a religious
text which you believe or you don't
believe
i produced a professional
k analysis of a case file
craig presented this in a language which
would be interesting to read for readers
and not a bureaucratic language it was
originally written by me
so
it requires you know each intelligence
agency had its own modest apparent die
and analysis this particular analysis is
based on inside knowledge of this modus
operandi because i was there at that
time
i was involved in a parallel operation
of
basically identical
so
it requires a certain knowledge of
professional detail and i'm ready to sit
down with any professional
in this field intelligence county
intelligence service
officer and to go
paragraph by paragraph sentence by
sentence of the story of trump kgb
relations and try to disapprove
not just say i don't believe it tell me
where
tell me what you don't believe and i
will explain
well let's go let's just let's start by
uh assuming it's right
that that you've um you've exposed an
operation an active measures operation
that was maintained for a period of 40
years or a little less than 40 years
perhaps um
with an individual who
becomes politically prominent
and rises ultimately to be president of
the united states
and then you continue to exercise at
least some measure of influence over him
during his presidency and thereafter
things going on afterwards um so i put
it to you that this is
the most successful
russian intelligence operation of all
time is that right
i i well
i'm not an expert on russia but i think
the the flip side of it is that it's
most serious national security failure
uh perhaps it's a civil war in the
united states since john wilkes wilkes
booth
yuri you're the you're the intel the
russian intelligence professional yes
anything you can think of that's better
than this
uh it is the big biggest success in
history but there is a caveat because
it wasn't the result of a well-planned
operation they had been conducted for 40
years
they were just working the guy
working the operation and then the stars
the stars angled in a special way and it
just happened
so it happened sometimes it was a fluke
just a streak of good luck for them
i believe that
they realized that this candidate donald
trump
has a reasonable chance to be to become
the next president of the united states
somewhere at the end of march or early
april
2016.
before that
no one in moscow
had any calls
this department
and
when they realized they threw the entire
capability everything they had
to help him
they
introduced into the operation the agents
which had been operational in the united
states in the early 70s
serious
very good
uh
camouflaged people
and unfortunately
unfortunately for them for the russians
when they
started working on this in full gear
this is where they expose themselves by
the way it is interesting maybe it would
be interesting to listen as to know that
the whole russian
meddling into 2016 uh presidential
campaign in the united states it was
from the kgb point of view
madness
i remember when i just joined the
department number one which was american
department
my first boss who had
in total about eight years
uh of posting
in the united states very experienced
gentleman
he told me that you know what we have
capability to intervene and to influence
to some extent presidential elections in
the united states but we're not going
we're not going to do that
because if you do this kind of a
preparation it should be absolutely
confidential which is very hard no one
would wish that it would be absolutely
confidential but if we fail
and americans will notice that we are
involved
the negative ramification of this
failure will be
just horrendous for our country and this
is exactly what happened for kremlin
after donald trump was elected the
president but the exposure of his
connection with russia just put them in
a corner and he couldn't help russian to
the extent they they they expected this
to happen
well um so let's let's switch to uh to
uh uh a different subject so it seems to
me you know reading over this book as a
whole
um it's a tapestry
um and they're
they're many different um yarns that
flow through it so you know certainly
the principle one is
um russian intelligence the russian
intelligence
recruitment operation and the active
measures
another is which i was rather surprising
to me is opus dei
figuring in a very very prominent way
another is bill barr and all the
kirkland and the ellis uh
lawyers who seem to heavily populate
um this um uh
past uh presidency the trump presidency
and another is jeffrey epstein and all
of his doings um in which you offer um
uh analysis i think many many uh people
before have hinted that but you i think
go quite a bit further in suggesting the
linkage between these activities and
those of um
of intelligence services but let's just
step back to you know these main two
strands of opus dei and russian
intelligence so
why would
opus dei
not expose a russian intelligence
operation
if they knew about it if they'd learned
about it why would they allow it to go
forward
unexposed that's
i think puzzling
to most people who look at it well i
think the most obvious answer is power
uh opus dei is an exceedingly weird
mysterious group and it goes its roots
go back to fascist spain
and it's very authoritarian in nature uh
i kept trying to find uh
you know exactly i were there links
between opus dei and russia and no i
couldn't find a single one what i could
find is that they uh attached themselves
to uh william barr
very early on he was uh
uh on the board of directors of the
catholic information center which is the
operational headquarters of focus day in
washington he says he's not in opus dei
they say he's not an open state but the
truth is it's a secret society and the
nature of a secret society is it's
secret so you really don't know and they
do lie at times and they have a doctrine
of um
uh forgive me the
where they can rationalize almost
anything to the point of lying
um and you see this small group of
people the even the board of the
catholic information center uh was
centered near the fbi uh robert hansen
was in
the great the the spy russian spy
uh who worked in who was with the fbi
was in opus dei
his brother-in-law happened to be the
chief speechwriter for william barr
when he was attorney general the first
time around under president george h.w
bush and you see them also allied with
members of the
federalist society which of course is
this uh large much larger uh deeply
conservative
group uh one of the key people there is
leonard leo
and uh who has uh vetted i believe the
last six republican supreme court
justices so they have enormous clout
there and they want uh
they want those judges they they want to
wipe out roe v wade uh it's an ex you
know and they've essentially taken
enormous power throughout the judiciary
it also happens to overlap oddly enough
with as you say law firms like uh
kirkland and alice an immensely rich uh
law firm
which happens to represent a lot of
roads and oligarchs and there's big
money coming in from them uh and they
end up in a lot of those attorneys ended
up in bill barr's uh justice department
so there was this great accumulation of
power
and uh i think there is sort of a shared
ideology between
the theology of opus dei which is very
very authoritarian and the kind of
imperial presidency that uh uh william
barr advocated and used to enable donald
trump to become
almost dictatorial and and that's sort
of the direction i see things going in
so yuri let me flip it around a little
bit for you i mean and ask you know how
would russian intelligence view a group
like opus dei i mean russian
intelligence of course has
well-documented relations with the
russian orthodox church that's been sort
of a a key part of operations for a very
long period of time
on the other hand you know it's had
quite a bit of hostility towards many
other uh religious groups and the
catholic church in particular i think
has been suspect and subject of
repression um and the certainly in the
communist period that was that was the
case so how do you understand this
relationship
uh between fsb the the foreign service
kgb
and opus dei
uh well
i don't i don't
this is this is attitude rather than
relationships
which was surprising for me but i can
explain something here
it was especially evident under putin
under his administration people in
moscow and kremlin they're prone to
conspiracy series
they like everything secretly
and they
believe in theories which are close to
what q anon is distributing they believe
that there is some kind of cabal
somewhere out there
uh a group of powerful people which
who pull the string
and make the world work it work and
they're plotting against russia they
want to destroy mother russia
and sometimes they generate this series
and then
they start believing because this series
goes through mass media et cetera give
me another one example on in yeltsin's
administration in kremlin there was a
guy he was two-star fsb general his name
was rogozin
he was involved in some kind of para
psychology
and he generated an idea that
america wants to take over siberia
because of envy that there are so many
natural resources there
uh he was a question how did you know
that he said that you know madeleine
albright
the secretary of state of the united
states at the time
we penetrated into her mind and what we
saw there in her mind was hatred towards
russia
and the desire to take over siberia this
is what these crazy guys really believe
and you know what right now
in you can you can very often run onto
this uh
story in the russian social media
networks there is no reference to
regarding anymore this story leads by
itself this is the fact already that
madeleine albright wanted to take over
siberia so this explains why they're
interested in different in everything
that seems or is secret
and has this cloud of you know
exclusivity
so i can explain just
by this but during the time of the kgb
this series was just of the wall we had
strict so-called objective or principle
of penetration based on
objects
object meaning
government institutions pentagon white
house
uh cia fba et cetera these are the main
objects and then intermediary objects
such as think tanks law firms lobbying
firms etc but they were no opposed day
or some biddelberg clap which you know
which which
they're very uh concerned with right now
in russia in moscow yeah but i i think
we've got just a few minutes left so i
think though the last subject i've got
to talk about to you it's got to be
jeffrey epstein right we haven't quite
gotten to any discussion of him um
although he winds up being almost in the
exact center of the book um and some of
the really most remarkable chapters so
what are the ties here between epstein
and professional intelligence services
russian intelligence
and trump uh you know
what what unites all these things how
are they tied together well to me what i
saw on that scene you know most people
write about him as running a a sex
trafficking ring which of course is true
but it was also a compromise factory and
i looked for his links to various
intelligence sources and uh
uh i had one israeli uh agent tell me he
saw
uh uh
epstein with robert maxwell in london in
maxwell's office and maxwell himself is
glenn maxwell's father the uh the great
british press baron who who had enormous
intelligence ties to you very close to
general kurzkov who is head of the kgb
uh so there are certainly questions
about that and you see it throughout the
whole epstein operation um i interviewed
among other people
a man named john mark dugan who was a
deputy sheriff in palm beach county
while epstein was being investigated and
i tracked him down in moscow uh
john mark dugan to me reminded me of a
guy from a refugee from an elmore
leonard
uh novel and uh he had uh been given he
told me 478 files
of
478 dvds
of apparent sexual activities because
epstein had cameras in all these rooms
in his various residences where he was
um
uh taping sec uh people
you know that he was collecting the
dirty little secrets of the richest and
most powerful people in the world but
what does this have to do with trump
that's that's that's the the part we
haven't yet crossed well epstein and
trump were good good friends for 15
years
um and it started around 1987 that
friendship uh it their friendship blew
up uh in the early 2000s and it was
over this famous palm beach mansion that
ethene very much wanted to buy and that
uh uh donald trump
after consulting with it scooped it out
from under his nose
and then flipped it he sold it for
double the price
to the russian oligarch uh rebelove
uh so that ended their friendship
and uh not long afterwards epstein was
showing around photos of donald trump
with a couple of uh young women or girls
i don't know their age uh but what's
your specific evidence for that
uh
yeah i talked this was a uh off the
record a background source
who said he saw it
uh is it
it's not fully conclusive but but you
could see uh trump turned on epstein
very very much after this period
so yuri um why would this be of interest
to to moscow to russian intelligence
oh
um well this story deserves a separate
book
written by mike craig
because what we have here is two
unprecedented since world war ii events
first honey trap
the kgb used honey traps but mostly
domestically they never
on very rare occasions they used it
outside of the soviet union by
herniatrim they they
they met
beautiful ladies which seduced
[Music]
high-level officials generals
scientists etc
now uh
they
use it massively in western europe and
in the united states and they use it in
the biggest after the end of world war
ii operation russian intelligence
operation
in the years of last years of war for
world war ii the russians were stealing
a bomb in the united states
now there after
artificial intelligence and so-called
super computer
uh there is obsession in the kremlin
that who is the first
to
get the
computer and every artificial
intelligence will run the world and this
is where this operation comes
comes in
it is massive it involves hundreds if
not thousands of people russian agents
operating in this country and what craig
describes is just a tiny bit tiny
example of this
so so now we're going to turn the floor
back over to severe to moderate uh q a
session
i'm sorry to interrupt that a
fascinating conversation but i think we
have
a good question to pivot off of yuri's
answer to start with
which is from james who asks is the
trump case unique have there been any
similar fsu slash su
deep penetration of politics or
corporations
operations in any other key western
countries since 1980
um
well if this is a question for me uh
i've been working on the united states
and my focus was always on on the united
states uh my knowledge about perform for
russian penetration in western europe is
is professional but it's pretty much
peripheral
uh
i've been doing business security
investigations which left
brought me some information showing that
the russians uh over the last about 10
years
have
unprecedented penetration into the uk
in political and business cycles of the
uk
they have business they have big success
in penetrating in germany and in france
right i would just uh like to add
something i mean i i would add the
entire republican party if you look at
it i mean it it and it happens in many
different ways
many of which happen to be legal that is
uh
you know if a new coal mine appears in
kentucky and it's tied to oleg derapaska
well
he of course is an oligarch who is very
very close to vladimir putin and that's
why uh mitch mcconnell is sometimes
called moscow mitch and if you look at
uh some of the campaign contributions uh
the republican senatorial campaign
uh committee gets lots of money from
lenin blavatnik who's a naturalized
american uh so it's perfectly illegal
but he's also a russian oligarch and uh
uh i've written about this in two books
and it's just incredibly widespread now
uh throughout the republican party and i
think that's why we see a lot of the
craziness uh as to what it's become it's
very much like the party of regions in
ukraine which is essentially a political
party for vladimir putin
that actually helped answer a few other
questions which revolved around the
republican parties represent
repre well excuse me the republican
party's relationship
with
the
russian compromise right i mean it's
astonishing to me i i grew up in dallas
and the republic you could not be more
right-wing and anti-communist
than uh the people i grew up with and to
see the same political party uh turning
a blind eye to all this is just
extraordinary
and our next question is someone playing
devil's advocate who asks
how has russia directly benefited
from having trump as an agent if it
didn't
if it did so
isn't it actually much worse off its
economy is stagnant tech base is
declining
capital flight has soared we are seeing
massive protests
putin is widely reviled nato is reviving
and sanctions are spreading
across the movement
right well i mean if you look do you
want to
go ahead
well i will i will i will pick it up
if you look at all the favors uh trump
has done for the republicans it's just
enormous
and uh putin wanted to put
was constantly saying american democracy
is corrupt well now at least 70 million
trump supporters absolutely believe that
and they believe the presidential
election was stolen and i think
relatively speaking the united states is
much weaker that may not address uh all
the questions uh
your your uh uh the uh other person
raised
but uh
the damage to the west has been
absolutely enormous and it's gonna take
us quite a while to recover
um the problem with this operation is
that the russians the putin's secret
services they blew it
as i explained earlier to previous
questions when they started massively
uh helping
uh trump to be to become real elected
they exposed his connections with moscow
and they basically by doing so they put
him in the corner
they everybody started talking that he's
connected to russia this is putin puppet
and
he could not do in this situation he
couldn't do as much as he could have
been done if it was secret you know so
russians exposed him and neutralized his
capability to help
to help them
more efficiently but he did help he
helped a lot what he did uh he put on
hold many of uh initiatives
basically most of them were initiated by
the u.s house
the laws about different sanctions
imposed on russia on different uh
over the previous four years
most of them
were
put on hold or made less effective than
they could could have been so
i mean the putin finally
he got the result of his fail
by exposing trump
but on the other hand there was
something something which
helped russians to make these sanctions
less painful
and
less damaging to the russian economy
because you know the analysts in russia
they say that if all sanctions which are
embedded into law past lost
past over the last four years had all of
them been implemented russian economy
would have been dead by now
i just add a couple of things here too i
mean it seems to me that there are two
areas
where trump made a huge difference for
russia um that were advantageous to
russia not at all advantageous to the
united states the first of them is oil
and gas so
trump reversed course on a series of
policies aiming at energy
diversification in order to double down
on fossil fuels
and that's not remotely beneficial to
the united states i mean maybe west
virginia a little bit but that's hugely
beneficial to russia
because the russian economy really is a
fossil fuels economy they needed those
exports that's that's the key uh to
their economic development because putin
failed to do diversification and the
second thing is nato
so trump from from the 80s
doing as much damage to nato as possible
was always a high priority uh for russia
and russian intelligence that's the this
uh newspaper ad that
that craig mentioned and yuri talked
about uh before that was all targeting
nato and nato operations and trump from
the instant he came in was doing
everything he could possibly do alone to
undermine the sound governance and
coordination of strategy that are the
principle purposes of nato he weakened
it so those are just two things
yeah and the russian reactions when he
was elected the president it was evident
it was decession of the russian duma
russian parliament was interrupted
when
one deputy
he was beaming with joy and pride
announced ladies and gentlemen donald
trump is elected the president of the
united states right now he's addressing
the nation and it was standing ovation
it was like they won the war
and then a couple days later one deputy
shows up it was on youtube
he is raising the toast saying that
america is ours without a single shot
this is what it means aggressive and
professional foreign policy of president
putin
and this
message was spread by the kremlin's
propaganda
over entire russian population and the
idea that our guy
recruited and
is the handler of this guy who was
who was always the big guy you know
right and now our guy is the master and
this one is center it's supported to put
his popularity you know
it was
it was a real big achievement for his
for his pride and even for his
popularity in the population
and i think all of this is a war of
sorts and it's a war
a new kind of war without bombs or
bullets or boots on the ground but it's
cyber warfare it's a war on truth it's a
war of using corruption as weapons it's
a war of looking at all the loopholes in
the american system whether it's
campaign finance corruption through
campaign financing uh through big rich
white shoe lawyers uh
and all sorts of things and no
i mean that's why i i keep saying it's
so important to have a real
counterintelligence investigation to get
to the bottom of how all this happened
so unfortunately we only have time for
one more question and to make things
easy i'm going to ask a meaty one to end
up
which
essentially uh reads
how do we
understand the communication between
russia the kremlin and trump
is it a matter of ideological alignment
or is there a consistent thread of
communication through secondary figures
within trump's ordinance
well i don't think we have all the
answers to this and and when it gets to
the subject of compromise i think one
thing is pretty clear is if you look at
all the conversations between uh trump
and putin the russians have them and we
don't
and and we really need that and that's
one thing they can hold over him
um i i don't think there needs to be a
constant back and forth and then in a
lot of ways the way this materialized
was sort of uh you scratched my back
i'll scratch yours and creating a
favorite back and forth
um
and and you can see what trump got out
of it uh very early on when i mean if
you go back to 1984 he had begun
effectively allowing trump real estate
to launder money millions and millions
of dollars uh for the russian mafia and
i found 13 uh russians who were either
mobsters or had uh intelligence ties
either owning or living in trump tower
and from properties that's a lot of
mobsters i think
but if there were other secret
communications
well if they're secret i don't know all
the secrets
i i agree i mean it seems it seems to me
that you know what we don't know is is
quite alarming uh you know
remember the very first days of the
administration when trump came in there
was a lot of talk that we learned about
later about establishing a back channel
of communication not using
white house secure comms and things of
that sort uh to allow to facilitate this
sort of communication you know what the
hell is all that about and what
communications actually occurred you
know we still don't know many details um
and i guess i've talked to people um on
the
national security staff uh in the trump
administration who have told me
repeatedly that you know one thing that
really alarmed them was that they would
discover
that uh trump had communications with
putin directly and it wasn't a scheduled
call it was nothing they knew about and
people in the white house learned about
these calls when they appeared on a
readout from the kremlin
which is pretty bizarre
so this was going on all the time sort
of violation of all the protocols and
that's not even getting into
you know meetings at the g7 uh where uh
where uh trump walked over to putin's
table uh and sat down
and had a conversation with him without
even his own translators so putin's
translator did the translation i mean i
challenge you to show me any other case
where an american president did things
like this i mean they're good reasons
why they wouldn't
so there are loads of unanswered
questions on this comms issue i think
i'll give another example that happened
just before
uh trump was elected in october of 2016
donald trump jr gave a speech in paris
at a french think tank uh and and uh it
happens you know he was paid fifty
thousand dollars plus all that's
perfectly legal of course what was
unusual is the french think tank is
widely said to be uh
a front for russian intelligence and he
was passed a talking point donald trump
funerals past talking points on
uh
what policy the russians wanted trump to
carry out in the middle east once he he
got
uh got into office and sure enough trump
did exactly what they wanted when he
pulled troops out of syria abandoned our
kurdish allies and left the russians in
charge of it now all of that was
perfectly legal every little step of it
was legal but it was part of a larger
intelligence operation
actually
he was not donald trump was not
micromanaged he was micromanaged and he
got the assignment after
uh during his first trip to moscow 1987
and actually he published this
assignment in three major american
newspapers upon his return from moscow
he published his view on world affairs
in washington post new york times boston
globe and the idea was we need to
unravel we need to
break all our national security
agreements with our traditional allies
to help with nato we'll get together
with russia and we too
will run will rule the world so it's
bipolar
world this is what russia has been
looking for for decades and that's what
he's been doing
when specific questions arises obviously
he was not doing this for for for the
idea for ideology i believe it was
forced his ego
his vanity
and
uh and money and money
when
the necessary necessity
arise for specific uh
uh issues to solve he had a line of
communication i'll i will outline you
just one he has rudy giuliani
he can tell what he needs to know to
rudy giuliani rudy giuliani goes to him
where he communicates with two higher
level russian intelligent
intelligence agents he tells them
what is required what the boss
wants these guys they take private jets
they fly to moscow and they communicate
this to the fsb or to put it and then it
goes backwards channels they have
channeled communication
and then openness openness in
intelligence sometimes is the best cover
for
intelligence espionage activities and
this is exactly what scott
described just now when they
communicated
in unusual circumstances
breaking all
possible protocols which existed
on that note i want to thank all three
of you craig yuri and scott for a
disturbing but like interesting
conversation
uh
on that note to our audience thank you
so much for joining us this evening if
you have yet to purchase a copy of
american compromise there is a helpful
green button which says purchase in the
center of your screen you can click on
and uh to everyone thank you and good
night
thank you good night thank you thank you
and good night
you're watching book tv on zspan2
every weekend with the latest